[Música]
[Aplausos]
garantir uma educação pública de
qualidade para todos deveria ser nosso
grande sonho com o país deveria ser a
nossa única meta em comum
senão ela que outra que outro grande
projeto a gente tem como agente nega
oportunidade para as crianças
garantir uma educação pública de
qualidade para todos é grande e ficar
cada um possa usar o máximo do seu
potencial
a primeira vez que eu tive a
oportunidade de refletir sobre isso em
a gente estava debatendo sobre a lei de
destinar 75 por cento dos royalties do
petróleo para a educação
e aquele debate meio que envolveu a
sociedade
ele arrastou um outro debaixo de uma lei
que seria votado em voltar em 2014 10%
do pib para a educação
isso era um número meio a candy qualquer
raciocínio nosso mas aquilo era uma
mensagem era olha o nosso país vai
investir 10% de tudo que a gente tem no
futuro das nossas crianças
mas bom dois projetos de muito
investimento em educação e eu estava em
taubaté no colégio particular de renome
o pessoal não gostou muito daquilo como
assim
a lógica era simples putz
o mercado de trabalho está muito difícil
entrar na faculdade particular
é complicado a gente vai qualificar
aquele pessoal pra mim ficou difícil já
está difícil agora a gente vai investir
na educação deles que vou fazer e bom
aquilo me incomodou de uma falta de
empatia lhe tinham medo era um
pensamento mesquinho conhecer o outro
lado ninguém estava muito animado meu em
como não me causa uma vontade queria
estudar um pouco sobre a educação
pública entender a realidade do meu
município a realidade do país
eu tive uma grata surpresa meu município
que em são paulo eu tinha educação
razoável pessoal poder pra aula não
chovia na sala de aula os professores
não faltava gente inclusive em colégio
público de renome estadual mas eu tinha
uma notícia muito triste isso é exceção
a gente tinha por mais que colocamos 98%
das nossas
essas hoje em sala de aula pouquíssimas
completo ensino médio muitas não chegam
a aula porque tem fome ou a aula é comer
então é uma questão de sobrevivência
eu quis compartilhar todas essas
novidades eu estava no segundo ano que
compartilhar com meus amigos não demorou
muito para que eles entendessem que não
era um sentimento de competição não era
putz vou qualificar aqueles alunos eles
vão roubar a minha vaga era diferente
a gente não pode pensar num país tendo
uma âncora e não era pensar não era vou
ajudar eles para que eles não sejam uma
âncora era putz
a gente tem privilégio e foi a primeira
vez que a vida estava convidando a gente
rever esse fato
nossos privilégios porque não consegue
estudar que nem a gente demorou muito
pra quem se juntasse a nós quais
particulares como chamar o pessoal do
colégio público pois vão pra rua falar
que a gente quer uma educação pública de
qualidade e se estão votando uma lei de
75 por cento dos sócios do petróleo para
investir em educação a gente quer que
ela seja aprovada
a gente foi pra rua fizemos um barulho
na cidade sexta-feira paramos o jornal
no dia seguinte falou que a gente era o
filho da geração dos caras pintadas mas
não era como se o brasil tivesse
escutado a gente estava em taubaté não
era nem manifestações de 2014 ainda que
para o país mas estar ali
diversos alunos do colégio público é o
reconhecimento de que a educação x é uma
pauta de todos e uma educação pública
por mais que você não fosse o
usufrutuário dela era uma luta também
sua foi a primeira vez que o pessoal
entendeu
se a gente não trabalhar junto o país
nem andar ea gente tem que pensar também
no outro jovem talento cajado e nesse
sentimento todos 2014 veio a gente
estava em vésperas de eleições faltando
em oito meses no início do ano e começou
pelos vinte centavos mas diversas pautas
estavam latentes de discussão vieram
calorosamente por santos abate e virou
jargão político 10% do pib para a
educação era como se todo mundo tivesse
certeza que a gente precisa investir no
nosso futuro então a gente meio que
superou aquela discussão de putz
será que investir na educação pública é
criar concorrência pra mim própria mim
mesmo
a gente resolveu trabalhar junto mas não
se enganem ali nessa imagem não no mar
era a gente chegando perto de todos era
tu era todos tendo a única oportunidade
de estudar
a gente trabalha junto e toda essa todo
esse sentimento me criou os dois todos
esses dois eventos nem criaram duas
crianças bem no meu íntimo e que me
inspiraram os meus projetos daqui pra
frente com duas palavras do jovem e
educação
o jovem porque houve na prática que o
jovem consegue pautar o debate
o jovem consegue impactar na hora de
descer e educação porque eu estava no
meio da gente continuar pensando em
brasil era o único meio de pensar de
fato no brasil em 2014 não sei vocês mas
parece que todo jovem tinha aquele
sentimento de que eu consigo mudar meu
país sozinho todo mundo foi para a rua
tinha certeza daquilo que eu tive uma
surpresa descobrir que um grupo de
amigos meu estava escrevendo um
manifesto o manifesto potente
eles queriam jogar luz sobre educação em
vésperas das eleições presidenciais
eles entrevistaram 100 personalidades
educacionais jesus presidente da
república secretário de educação ex
ministros empresários do tema e divulgar
um manifesto mapa do buraco porque esse
nome a gente estava apontando todos os
buracos da educação brasileira e todos
os possíveis gargalos
era como que político você está se
candidatando para resolver isso e tem
noção mas calma a gente está apontando
também práticas positivas se quer dar
uma olhada no documento
o documento foi lançado de maneira
suprapartidária e causou um rebuliço
a gente fez questão de entregar em mãos
para todos os candidatos à presidência
da república inclusive diversos
governadores candidatos a senadores
todo mundo que tinha o mínimo de
interesse em educação tava sabendo desse
documento
e a gente tem um sonho que as eleições
presidenciais de 2014 fossem as eleições
da educação pública de qualidade
a gente realizou a única sabatina
educacional no segundo turno das
eleições de ms
mandaram seus representantes máximos
educacionais para debater a educação
mas eu acho que vocês sabem que não foi
a educação que definiu qualquer eleição
a pauta foi tomada meramente por debates
públicos e um debate as pautas
econômicas e de corrupção nos debates
televisivos
a gente não chegou a ouvir sequer uma
pergunta sobre educação em um país que a
gente colocou 98 por cento dos jovens na
sala de aula mas que a gente continua
formando ensino médio de cada 100 alunos
23 conseguem compreender textos e 11
conseguem resolver problemas
tem algum descompasso se acaba se nos
últimos cinco anos antes das eleições
presidenciais a educação já figurava
entre as três maiores preocupações
brasileiros onde estava o político não
escutava tinha um descompasso muito
grande a gente resolveu 11 fundar o
movimento uma educação um grupo de
jovens que quer engajar se você se viu
no debate sobre educação que qualificar
informar mais movimento na educação nos
últimos dois anos realizou diversos e
teve diversas iniciativas desde levar os
100 jovens mais destacados com projetos
educacionais suprir lacunas que o estado
não conseguem chegar a brasília para
conversar com o governo para conversar
com empresários e dá uma rede grande de
neto 8 a qualificar jovens com programas
de liderança mas hoje a gente chegou no
nosso grande projeto que ele está
rodando agora o mapa nas eleições para
as eleições eles surgiu de uma reflexão
sabiam que a figura federativa mais
importante do país quando a gente fala
de educação pública no município
não adianta falar puxa presidente
governador deputado federal e eles têm
com passar leis eles têm sua importância
mas gestão escolar quem tem impacto é o
prefeito
todos sabiam disso não sei mas vale a
reflexão por votos agora é prefeito e
bom a gente quer conscientizar todo
mundo disso a gente está mandando 14
perguntas dos candidatos das três
maiores capitais do país são paulo rio
salvador são os três maiores colégios
eleitorais ea gente acha que isso é
representativo
qual sua visão geral sobre educação
como valorizar a carreira do professor
informação e salarialmente como você
escolheu o secretário de educação
ele é um cara indicado o que ele pensa
o que você pensa sobre o projeto escola
sem partido está tramitando no colégio
no congresso nacional
a gente acha que com essas quatro
perguntas a gente consegue deixar bem
claro para o leitor o que em quem está
votando não funciona mais ou menos assim
tive essas quatro perguntas para todos
os candidatos estão lançando vídeos
online nas duas páginas de maior
engajamento do facebook
isso dá em torno de 11 milhões de
pessoas de lights naquela hora
o projeto bongô tanto que a maior rede
televisiva do país nos procurou que eles
querem divulgar o nosso vídeo na íntegra
no estúdio ir pra quem quiser ver gente
joga esse vídeo em três minutos a gente
contextualiza então se você nunca teve
interesse educação você vai saber mais
ou menos o que é uma visão geral de
educação do município com dados
econômicos e educacionais
os candidatos vão responder com um vídeo
de até um minuto ea gente vai colocar em
maneira de debates só que a gente vai
reservar o direito à tréplica
se algum candidato fizer uma proposta
real a gente vai perguntar candidato é
sério mas você não tinha nem competência
pra vocês como prefeito é uma proposta
falsa ctl da a5 educação mesmo a gente
acha que isso vai ter um impacto mas por
mais que são paulo rio salvador seja os
três maiores colégios eleitorais do país
a gente tem um quinteto de fato em
milhões de crianças
a gente acha que chegar em cidades
longínquas também é importante
nosso time - a gente tomou um terceiro
setor não tem muito dinheiro então tem
como a gente mandar gente para tudo
quanto é canto
mas a gente fez 14 a action e ele já foi
respondido jovens
você quer impactar as eleições da
sociedade você pode falar com a gente a
gente vai te orientar em relação a toda
a legislação eleitoral que você tem que
respeitar ea gente já te ajuda a bola
perguntas analisando os dados
socioeconômicos e educação educacionais
a sociedade a idéia não é pegar o
candidato onde ele não tá nem vendo a
ideia é perguntar dados que ele deveria
estar sabendo o candidato a prefeito
você está qualificado porque a gente não
acha que você deveria assumir a
prefeitura a sociedade se você não tem
um plano educacional forte
a educação não pode ter renegado a mais
quatro anos de gestão para depois ser
pensado educação a gente tem que começar
a ser pensada hoje todos estão
convidados inclusive estão aqui
a idéia é que cada jovem se tiver o
mínimo de interesse e impactar as
eleições do seu município não precisa de
dois jovens um só se ele conseguir jogar
luz nesse debate na cidade dele ele
consegue fazer alguma diferença e essa
mudança que vem de baixo é um pouco
diferente ela faz um barulho em cima mas
ela precisa de várias vozes se no início
eu falei para vocês que educação pública
de qualidade deveria ser o nosso grande
sonho como país um assunto sonho é uma
opção diária é como se estivesse acordar
todo dia se perguntar putz que eu já fiz
pra educação do meu país hoje ea gente
não pode nunca esquecer daquele daquela
reflexão que eu só tive a oportunidade
de ter um ensino médio às vezes alguns
antes às vezes alguns só depois a gente
tem muito privilégio a gente tem que
ajudar a quem não teve oportunidade
são condições mínimas uma pessoa tem que
conseguir estudar se não nunca vai
conseguir desenvolver o seu potencial é
como se estivesse perdendo diversos
brasis possíveis e não dá pra fazer isso
a gente tem que fazer a opção da escolha
pela agenda nacional de educação todo
dia e só assim a gente vai começar a
pensar no brasil no futuro
mas o brasil do presente muito obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]